[Music]  when you want to draw a charge you  forget about your defensive position you  just get straight so you use letter  movements so that's when I use my lungs  lateral step  [Applause]  [Music]  twisting  [Applause]  to always watch  whatever is needed  - [ __ ] I've done it since I remember  playing last ball I and I did it in the  Middle East and nobody mentioned the  uniqueness of my steps so when I got  here and then they put a name on it and  you know everybody started doing it so I  guess there was something different  [Applause]  [Music]  some people say manager knows the best  nice little Ginobli European step the  euro staff in the school Wow  will it be the final game of a brilliant  career of Manu ginóbili for modelling  and he definitely deserved that moment  always gone for the game of basketball  [Applause]